probability right what it is it's the
mathematics of chance we had a look
recently at like things like saying
measurement right measurement geometry
there the mathematics of size of space
of quantifying and there's each
individual branch and each is the
mathematics is something in particular
right so what I want to try to do is for
a parallel between algebra and
probability right
do you remember algebra is the
mathematics of something do you remember
what it was why do we introduce like X's
and Y's in tournaments yeah very good so
I mean that particular way we said is
it's the mathematics of unknown numbers
right so I'm gonna say that algebra
right it lets you work with you
unknown numbers even if you don't know
what its value is you can still
manipulate it you can multiply it added
subtract it find differences all that
kind of thing and probabilities kind of
in the same sort of vein right but
instead of working with unnerve numbers
just a little more specifically it's
about predicting what you've got
uncertain events so you don't say oh
there's something and you know it's an
even chance that it will happen okay or
it's pretty unlikely or it's you know
hurt summer goals whatever you like
couple of quotes these things it's a tea
yes okay it's fine it's fine
I just don't depend assumption now you
you can not know whether something is
actually going to specifically happen
but you could still just like algebra
you can still work with it you can still
make predictions right by the way just
before we leave this I really love this
it's nice and colorful I should have
bought a third color I wanna show you
there's a whole bunch of other words
that you can use and I've got some of
them here so just have a look at
something nice and small okay that's an
ad go away okay just have a look at some
these I love how many of these you ready
that's right we already have some of
their 50-50 chance of a sporting chance
was that maybe like yeah fat chance that
won't really just me this is your fat
chance here and I think if I'm ready to
go down here here we go slim chance a
slim chance and fetch it now yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if yeah fat chance
my job um what does a fat chance mate
it's very very unlikely right what about
what's a slim chance very unlikely in
fact they mean the same thing right it's
enough money to fence the same thing
anyway um we got a whole bunch a
snowball's chance in hell
what does that mean what's that again
yeah it's another way of saying
impossible
not a chance the chance my fighting
chance I like that one
that seems racist to me but I don't even
know these hey you don't wanna turn it
on right see a chance to answer for
whatever you can see there's all these
idioms that we attached to be able to
describe when something's not certain
okay but I want to illustrate for you
the power of like how wonderful
probability can be even when you don't
know you can still know with a lot of
certainty I was drawing last night what
do you think what would you say
I probably say always it depends which I
know is a bit of a cop-out of an answer
but I think it does depend like this is
these are the intricacies of our our
funny little range all the rules that
are rules but our rules and their
exceptions and it's because I don't
think I could give you this okay now um
maybe wouldn't jot down this some is
phrase here Galton born the Galton was a
great little tool to demonstrate what I
mean by the power probability to work
with something that you don't know but
you you can predict amazing adversity
okay so I've got two Galton boards to
show you and I'm just gonna hit play on
this one and we can just enjoy alright
so this is a Gaussian board because the
first person to make one of these and
named after themself is called ionic
Galton and what you do is you take a
ball you drop it into the top and it
bounces off all these nails before
eventually going into one of these
categories and when the ball hits each
nail in theory there's a 50/50 chance of
it going left or right and so each path
is pretty much unpredictable if I was to
take two balls and put them in even if I
thought that they exactly the same they
will end up in completely different
positions we cannot accurately predict
where any given ball will go however we
can make a few statements we can say
that a ball is more likely to end up
then in the middle than the edge because
these Center categories there are lots
of different paths that end up here
there are only a few paths that end up
on the edge that's what we can do is
take this piece of scientific equipment
attach it to the top and start putting
these in by the handful if we put your
absolutely loads of these balls even
though each individual one we couldn't
accurately predict where it's going to
end up we can get we predict the overall
pattern from lot simpler
all right and that pattern we end up
with is called the normal distribution
in fact we've got a future maybe in the
middle there you know a lot of things in
nature follow this pattern if you may do
people's height they will follow a
normal distribution shoe sizes are a lot
of things in science and engineering and
maths match this kind of bell-shaped
curve okay so I'm just gonna pause there
cuz I'm about to show you another Galton
board did you see what he was talking
about and why probability factors into
this which it seems like it shouldn't
but it's quite amazing what you can
pretty it's like do you think I have
heads of steel okay so what he's talking
about is let me see if I can yeah there
we go so there's all the nails there
right left right left right left right
and because what they can do is think
about what we can do is think about the
chances of these on certain events left
or right you don't really know but if
you think about them on a long time
scale you can actually make very
accurate predictions I want to show you
this video here we go now this is
another Galton point I know it's a bit
hard to see but there's a hand up here
holding a release mechanism the
difference in this one and the previous
one is that rather than like balls these
are like grains of sand and these are
the nails or whatever they are a lot
closer together and smaller okay so this
goes by very quickly I'll probably play
it for you twice so just watch carefully
it was quick right let me watch it let
me play it again yeah they did make sure
well the guy before his name is Matt
Parker he's a funny guy
he mentioned that this is called the
normal distribution we're actually going
to look at that next year underneath
data statistics and it's a very
important bell curve shape we're going
to spend lots of time in there but this
is just an example of what I mean by
things can be on set and that does not
mean we can't work with them and predict
them just like